as opposed to having a blanket policy
and one treatment for everything all the
time everywhere say okay you know what
the infection fatality rate is so much
higher
the older you are
that
perhaps we should strongly encourage
more invasive treatments
the older you are and actually
discourage treatments that we know come
with costs the younger you are because
the younger you are the more likely you
are to get it not notice it than have
immunity and uh the idea of protecting
yourself against all costs and thus
leaving your immune system
um
potentially naive to it until a later
point at which point you will be more
susceptible is
batshit crazy medical policy is what it
is so this piece uh is was sent to us by
a fan this week i would not have run
into it otherwise and so this is in an
outlet called the gray zone which i
never heard of before
written by
an academic called christian parenti
published the last day of march of this
year title is how the organized left got
covered wrong learned to love lockdowns
and lost its mind and autopsy it's a
very long piece it's excellent
i'm just going to read the first two
paragraphs and this is written by a
left-leading academic as far as i can
tell i mean i think he says that in
there but you can also just kind of tell
that he is
he says it is hard to destroy your own
cause and feel righteous while doing so
yet the american left has done it after
more than two centuries at the vanguard
of the struggle for freedom the american
left broadly defined executed a volte
foss
i looked up how to pronounce this a
volte face i saw a lot of okay it means
an about face i don't know why we're
using that i'm going gonna start over
yeah okay oh hello uh it is hard to
destroy your own cause and feel
righteous while doing so yet the
american left has done it after more
than two centuries the vanguard of the
struggle for freedom the american left
broadly defined executed a volte face
and embraced anti-working-class policies
marketed as purely technical public
health measures
for two years the left has championed
policies of surveillance and exclusion
in the form of punitive vaccine mandates
invasive vaccine passports socially
destructive lockdowns and radically
unaccountable censorship by large media
and technology corporations for the
entire pandemic leftists and liberals
call them the lockdown left cheered on
unprecedented levels of repression aimed
primarily at the working class those who
could not afford private schools and
could not comfortably telecommute from
second homes
and he if i may thank you zach he then
he spends some time in that vein
and then says arguing reason against
covet hysteria is like attempting to put
out a magnesium fire using water but i
will try anyway
and he and then it's just
a reasonable argument after a reasonable
argument including this one about
actually a blanket policy a vaccinate
everyone immediately never made sense
given what this disease looks like
and
i don't think
i don't often feel like we've been
trying to put out a magnesium fire with
water but that is to some degree
when it has been on occasion we've also
been trying to figure out what
the narratives that are being used
against people are
so that we can help pull people out of
their anxiety and their fear and their
propagandized mindsets and start to see
something that's real again but it is it
is tough and i feel like this piece
along with increasing numbers of others
reveal that there are a lot of people
who are saying for for god's sake
can can we can we please get this
history right
else we are certain
to repeat it because there are some who
would like us to
well there is an epic battle to prevent
us from doing the post-mortem properly
right or if the postmortem is done
properly to demonize it in advance so
people won't be able to figure it out
and i must say i think a lot rests on
our ability
to override the force that would like us
not to do it yep um i will point out
that an epic battle is coming
uh over the difference between
um
[Music]
consequences in 2020 and 2021
because the point is anything that
happened as a result of our vaccine
policy will be easily blamed on covid
and the difference between what happened
in 2020 and 2021 is the place to see
that distinction
but
anyway very very interesting to hear
that that has emerged it sounds like
a very bold academic it will be
interesting to see what happens to him
[Music]